Ciao Gu
il trauma più grande io l'ho avuto col mio ex
E non solo  definire il  rapporto con un caffettino, quindi "Lo vuoi un caffettino?"
Ma durava quanto un caffetttino
E io mi accorgevo che era terminato e che avevamo finito
nel momento in cui cominciava a fare il classico rumore della caffettiere quando... *rumore caffettiera* ...ha finito
quando il caffè è pronto uno stridolio finale
Quindi ho dovuto cambiare bar e barista... in sette anni
Un amore ristretto
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di "Vita Buttata"
Il tema della puntata di oggi è
"Esperienze Sessuali Orribili"
Questo tema mi terrorizza particolarmente
L' unico motivo per cui lo sto facendo è perché è stato veramente richiesto tantissimoo
e quindi mi sono detto "Vabbè, o la va o la spacchi"
Troviamo un modo per cercare di mantenere questa cosa comunque dignitosa
Ed è così che ho pensato comunque di evitare all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una persona che è qui, per dei motivi che non posso dirvi
perché non voglio che questo canale venga chiuso
Sto parlando niente popò di meno che della mia carissima amica Valentina
Uuuuu. Ciao Vale. Ciaoo
Lo sai che l'inizio avevo un altro modo per presentarti?
Si sono molto contenta che tu abbia deciso di non tenerlo però
io avrei chiamato questa rubrica esperienze sessuali "penose"
Penose
E questo era tutto ragazzi ci vediamo alla prossima puntata
Ahahhaha mi stavi ammazzando!
Dove sta il computer nel quale... sennò ce li inventiamo "Ciao Guglielmo"
Ah credo che stia ancora nella mia borsa
Gianmarco aveva aperto la taschina del ... per cercare ahhahah (Enrico)
sta nella tasca del coso....sta nel mio portafoglio il computer
Tu hai avuto mai esperienze?
Non abbiamo tre ore eh
Allora mi ha detto una cosa Vale "Mi raccomando facciamo attenzione
perché c'è mia mamma "Ciao Mamma" che ci guarda. Saluta mamma
"Ciao "Marghe"
Quindi quello che ho pensato per rendere tutto questo decente, dignitoso
è stato quello di chiedere su Facebook e Instagram di mandarmi dei messaggi vocali
che non fossero troppo... espliciti! Espliciti!
Ma che in qualche modo indonassero la pillola con delle allegorie un pochino come Dante con la Divina Commedia
Senza contare che scusami! Ultimamente io ho visto una foto che ha messo tua madre. Vogliamo parlarne?
Nooo ragazzi non vogliamo parlarne. No no no parliamone
perché mi vede mia mamma ma poi comunque....
Lei ha messo le foto, proprio gli screenshot, nella bellissima scena
in cui io mangio la banana nel tuo video
Aaaaa
E quando io le ho chiesto "Mamma perchè?" Mamma ha risposto
"Beh io voglio il nipotino a breve, insomma non sei più carne giovane
e quindi devo pur mostrare al mondo che cosa sai fare!"
Riusciamo a partire? Riusciamo a partire o dobbiamo continuare a fare gli stupidi
e a far vedere che a trent'anni si può comunque rimanere con un quoziente intellettivo inferiore alla media. Eh?
Ma se io ne ho 19
Non farò battute........19 c***i!
Partiamo!
Trovai un piccolo volatile sdraiato sul mio letto che sembrava non avere nessuna voglia di volare
E allora lo presi, cercai di farlo riprendere, di guarirlo, ma continuò a non voler volare e a stare male
Io immagino questo uccello... monocolo che ti guardava "cosi" ma non poteva fare niente!
Ciao Gu ciao ospite volevo raccontarvi che una volta quando sono andata dal mio estetista
per farmi truccare mi ha chiesto di assaggiare la pasta con la panna che stava cucinando
Era la seconda volta in tutta la mia vita che l'assaggiassi
quindi sapevo che la pasta mi piaceva ma la panna no
e appena ho sentito il sapore della panna mi sono allontanata
e questo maccherone era pieno di panna quindi... è caduto
La panna è schizzata ovunque, tipo nei miei occhi, sul muro, per terra
e abbiamo dovuto pulire prima che arrivassero gli altri
Ragazzi!
Ciao Gu L'episodio di cui ti voglio parlare è successo qualche mese fa
Ero con la mia ragazza e come di solito preferisco fare sono diciamo entrato in casa col cappello
Evidentemente sono un tipo freddoloso
Il problema è stato che ne sono uscito senza!
Allora dopo qualche attimo di panico per ovvi motivi
e dopo qualche ricerca andata in fumo ho chiesto a lei di cercare in casa sua
ho detto "Vabbè magari la conoscerà sicuramente meglio di me!"
Il tutto ha avuto esito negativo
Dopo attimi di ulteriore panico ho detto
"Vabbè a sto punto cerco io in casa sua"
Fortunatamente dopo una ricerca non troppo forzata, non troppo esplorativa tra virgolette
Certo!
ho trovato il mio benedetto cappello, un po stropicciato ma l'ho trovato
Dora l'esploratrice! Cos'è?
Casa sua era...cioè comunque...a tre piani. A tre piani! comunque c'è quanti metri quadri di casa c'erano?
Però ricordatevi sempre che come diceva mia nonna
"La casa nasconde ma non ruba"
Ma che f**a c'aveva questa?
E' un cappello comunque ragazzi! Ok che la casa è grande! Ma è un cappello!
Beh dopo ti nascondo un cappello in casa e vediamo se lo trovi. Ti ringrazio!
In discoteca ci provo con questa ragazza. Siamo li un po che che ci stuzzichiamo
e dice all'orecchio che è la regina dei "Puffi", chiamiamoli così. Lei si inginocchia
Per vedere il mondo fatato dei Puffi. Ah certo, per essere all'altezza dei Puffi. Sisi ovvio
Se tu hai visto il cartone loro no stanno sugli alberi,. Stanno comunque...in mezzo ai funghi. In mezzo ai funghi
Mi fa questo Puffo,  tempo un minuto mi vomita addosso
Gargamella!
Sono la regina dei Puffi. Bahhh
Ragazzi scusateci per l'audio abbiamo avuto un piccolo problema
si è scaricata la videocamera sono andato a mettere in carica la batteria
e... non so in che modo si è staccata la spina, quindi il computer è impazzito
e fino ad adesso avete sentito un audio "così", come si dice
"Na m***a!
Riprendiamo adesso con diciamo un po di audio
Valentina che piacere averti qui con me. Mio caro. Tu e le tue maledizioni!
Ha fatto cilecca il computer, succede!
Buongiorno Gu, buongiorno anche all'ospite se è Luigi "Ciao Luigi". Nel caso non è...mi dispiace
La storia divertente è quando il mio fortunatamente ex ragazzo
stava per infilare la spina della corrente nella presa
quando prima però stava vedendo se era abbastanza carica con le dita
e ad un certo punto io gli ho detto "Si vabbè ma basta con le dita...mettici la...spina!"
E lui tipo si è girato e quasi messo a piangere perché in realtà era già dentro la spina
Oddio! Oddio! Che brutto lavoro l'elettricista!
Cioè questo rischiava di prendersi la scossa
E' tornato a casa un po bruciato secondo me. Eh immagino
Lei continua..."Cioè insomma lui...eh ce l'aveva piccolo
" Esplica...non l'avevamo capito! Grazie
Tu dici "Smettila di avere l'adattatore"
Eh no. Eh no! E insomma, e invece! Eh no
Parlando di spine poi tra parentesi... Era perfetto! "Maledette spine di m***a!" ... aggiungo
Ciao Gu ho visto il tema di questa settimana di "Vita Buttata" e ho detto "No è mio!"
Questo ragazzo ha deciso di portarmi, per stare un po tranquilli nel parcheggio di un cimitero
vicino ad un paese dove abito io
Non c'era anima viva ecco
La performance è andata malissimo perché il suo gingillo non collaborava per niente
nel senso che non raggiungeva livelli di altezza sufficenti
affinché potesse avvenire qualcosa
e poi mi detto che secondo lui il problema era della mia amichetta
Non so come fosse abituato a fare certe cose ma a casa mia
se io devo fare all'amore con qualcuno deve essere un po...
di marmo la situazione! Non se ci capiamo. Lapidaria!
E un bacione. Sei bellissimo, il tuo ragazzo è bellissimo, siete bellissimi che vita di m***a perché sono tutti gay?
Con me ha cercato di fare quello che io definisco l'effetto "Piegare la manica della..." Cioè fammi un ok col dito
E tu capito?  Cioè tipo cerchi di rimboccare
Si è l'effetto delle sarte
Ma tu hai avuto esperienze? Di che cosa stai parlando?
Io sono così casta e pura e c'è mia madre che guarda
Ok non tu, una tua amica
Allora...
C'è questa mia amica che li scegli proprio sempre col lanternino. Eh la conosco pure io mi sa
Ok. La peggiore che lei ha vissuto? Questa tua amica?
Allora questa mia amica si frequentava con un ragazzo un po più giovane...un po tanto più giovane
Oddio non so come dirlo!
Si parla sempre comunque un po di dimensioni  ma a parte la dimensione ridotta era la forma che era inquietante
Mi ha raccontato ovviamente che la forma era quella proprio di un ciuccio da bambini
Diciamo che ha deciso di non andare mai ...
Si...cosi!
I ciucci per i bambini che hanno tutta la cosina bella bella sopra
e poi sono più piccolini in fondo
Ecco dimensioni uguali, forma uguale e quindi...
Ma aveva anche l'anello il manico? (Enrico)
No fortunatamente. Si.Teoricamente si. Forse nascosto sotto
Mai più con quelli più giovani! E lei che cosa ha fatto?
E lei ha subito passivamente questa cosa. Questo inferno!
Un biberon (Gianmarco )
Esatto! Questo biberon. Si è fatta svezzare in qualche modo
Scusate chiudiamo qui!
Scusami Silvia se ho raccontato questa....
Ero in vacanza con degli amici e tornando dal mare prima per cucinare il pranzo
e faccio un bel sughetto con un bel po di peperoncino ovviamente spezzettato a mano
Ecco beh la mia ragazza torna prima degli altri... ci appartiamo in camera
Beh io non mi ero lavata le mani del peperoncino
Vi dico solo che ha passato un quarto d'ora sul bidet a sciacquarsi poverina!
Chili con carne. Pensavo più alle patatas bravas che sono...belle piccanti!
Vuoi un Succifrizzi?" Mi sembra a tema
Ho un dejavù
Ragazzi ve lo giuro!
Metti in bocca non lamentarti!
Tanto... Ho già fatto
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite
Allora la mia peggiore esperienza sessuale risale a circa tre anni fa
quando ero ancora fidanzata con il mio... ormai ex
Un giorno stiamo facendo cose ma a un certo punto lui mi dice
"Guarda...fermati!"
Io gli chiedo "Ma che è successo?"
E lui mi fa "Preferisco finire da solo"
Sono stata chiusa dentro al bagno dell'appartamento per... un quarto d'ora
a sentire lui dall'altra parte della porta sul letto e finire la cosa da solo
Ma perché? Preferisco fare da solo. Anzi, se puoi andare in bagno
Trac Trac
E' brutto comunque cioè il fatto che tu inizi a ballare
e poi dici...vieni  messa in un angolo. Vieni messa in un angolo!
Cioè è tutto quello che non ti insegna Dirty Dancing! Noo è sbagliato!
La tua baby merita di più
Attraverso una chat di incontri una sera dove avevo voglia di divertirmi
ho cominciato uno scambio di messaggi con questa persona
la quale però non riusciva a darmi la conferma sul fatto se ci saremmo visti in serata perché
mi scriveva delle cose come "No ma sai sono al lavoro, devo capire se puoi passare ricordati che sto lavorando!"
Alla fine mi da l'indirizzo di casa, vado, e scopro che in realtà lui faceva il badante
e che quindi mi aveva invitato a casa sua con i vecchi dentro
E quindi il rapporto sessuale, che non è neanche valso la pena si è dovuto consumare in completo silenzio
Beh ragazzi a me è successa una cosa simile...no non lo dico"! Dillo!
Sempre questa mia amica Silvia Si Silvia. Che salutiamo. Ciao Silvia
Abitava con la nonna e... non lo diciamo.
Non lo diciamo! Allora lei abitava con la nonna...lei abitava con la nonna
e quindi diciamo che quando il suo ragazzo veniva a trovarla a volte capitava
che la nonna magari dormisse...il desiderio era troppo
e quindi nel mentre tu sentivi la nonna poverina nella stanza accanto
che magari tossiva o lanciava qualche puzzetta
Era una cosa imbarazzantissima!
Perché sua nonna poverina ha sofferto un po di flautulenza nell'ultimo periodo
e quindi lei e il suo fidanzato con questo sottofondo musicale
Silvia!
Salutiamo la mamma di Valentina. Ciao Mamma. Era Silvia mamma!
Esco con il mio fidanzato dell'epoca ed andiamo in macchina
Penso che si sa che comunque lo spazio nelle macchine specialmente nei sedili posteriori è abbastanza stretto
e devi giocare un po di fantasia
Quindi noi optiamo per quella posizione che ha a che fare con un numero
Non so se si può dire
Comunque nel bel mezzo del tutto quindi dove io avevo davanti il suo coso e lui davanti la mia cosina
Abbiamo capito. Diciamo così
E iniziamo, insomma stavamo raggiungendo tutti e due il clou della situation
io decido di scoreggiare
Quindi si. Mi ha scorreggiato in faccia!
Ecco come Malgioglio diventa Malgioglio!
Na signora anche lei comunque!
Beh anche la nonna di Silvia
Un esperienza traumatica è stata quella avuta col mio ex mentre eravamo intenti a fare robe
Entra improvvisamente sua madre in camera
Mi vede chiaramente e palesemente col gingillo di suo figlio in mano
però continua imperterrita a prendere ciò che doveva prendere ed esce dalla camera
Dopo pochi secondi rientra nella camera col padre del mio ex al seguito
e per farsi perdonare mi da un mega Ferrero Rosher
dicendomi appunto scusa che era colpa sua insomma che non aveva bussato
Come se non bastasse dopo poco entra la sorellina
chiedendo divertita come mai fossimo tutti li e che cosa fosse successo
Un party di famiglia. Col Bounty in mano ancora. No grazie ho già lo snack!
Non se è stato peggio la volta in cui un bellissimo ragazzo tra l'altro mi ringhiò in faccia tutto il tempo
Oppure quando un altro si mese davanti e disse "Tò Celine Dion canta!"
No! Però "Celine Dion " è un professionista, è bellissimo. No!
Cioè questa qui s'è beccata "Tò Celine Dion canta!" e l'altro
*ringhio animalesco*
E Wolverine...Però sai che Celine Dion è più comune di quanto non pensi?!
Sempre Silvia?
Sempre Silvia!
Non proprio Celine Dion però si diciamo, lui cantava e voleva che anche lei cantasse
Non l'ho capita. Meglio! Andiamo avanti. Vediamo gli altri messaggi
In che senso lui cantava?...Andiamo avanti no davvero. No poi Silvia si arrabbia
Sembra che mi stai ravanando!
Mmm. Deliziosi!
Allora un'esperienza sessuale traumatica non è stata tanto l'esperienza in se ma il dopo
Infatti dopo essere usciti abbiamo deciso di appartarci in una zona abbastanza buia
e arrivati ad un certo punto comincio a vedere delle luci fisse dopo ovviamente aver finito
Cominciano a bussare nella macchina e sentiamo una voce che dice "Aprite! Aprite!"
E niente apriamo e c'era un poliziotto con la torcia puntata verso di noi
che ci guarda e dice "Vabbè sono due" e se ne va
Perchè se erano in cinque?
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
Io ringrazio Silvia...io ringrazio Vale per...
Io ringrazio Vale per essersi prestata
Insieme abbiamo surfato nella difficoltà. Mamma mia ragazzi! Ecco
Quindi se volete commentare fatelo mettetendovi una mano sulla coscienza
e utilizzando tanta tanta tanta fantasia
Credo che un sacco di artisti e di visionari abbiano fatto dei begli esempi ok?Si
Io invito inoltre a farmi saper qua sotto quali sono dei temi
che vi piacerebbe guardare all'interno di questa rubrica
e soprattutto vi do un appuntamento alla prossima settimana con un altro video
Ciao ciao
Tua madre t'ammazza.? No
Comunque mia mamma ha detto che ti ammazza se non le mandi Guldo, vuole una foto del tuo cane lo sai!
Sono sempre allegorie?